foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
so
[Music]
[Music]
to
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey everybody here we are in the naked
ass room again except for conan he's
still there yeah
man jenny just woke me up oh it's time
for the show i was sleeping i told you
before it was time for the show yeah he
had to get a lot of hours ago i fell
asleep it wasn't hours ago it was an
hour and a half ago
i don't know how long it was
he doesn't have any sense of time or
responsibility or anything i was [ __ ]
tired man [ __ ] lay down fell asleep
i'm tired too but yeah i got [ __ ] to do
okay but yeah so it's sunday i know this
is like a weird time for us to beside
like doing a show on sunday but
i felt bad for like not doing one
you know because we hadn't been doing
any matinee shows and we probably can't
do another one until wednesday because
we're moving all the
we're moving the bed to the new house
tomorrow
and
in the refrigerator and like all the
just the
few remaining generators pieces of
furniture generators generators yeah and
uh all the heavy stuff and then is the
internet supposed to be hooked up
tomorrow or tuesday
okay so i basically have to go to the
new house yeah and always leave the crew
to come here for the you know yeah for
the uh people to come and like hope yeah
make sure that you can do the whole land
thing if that's how you want to do yeah
because i need the i need the uh what do
you call it the router like up in the
office probably yeah if they'll do it i
mean i would think
because i need to be able to like hook
up the the land cable to this laptop
but yeah it's been
uh somebody asked him thank you
everybody for
saying happy birthday also wanted to
give a couple shout outs to
sandra
um who sent me some money on paypal for
my birthday
and also sophie who also sent me some
money for my birthday today yeah and
also i got it for 50 bucks
yeah i know it was like awesome and so
um also yesterday i got a package from
louie
and he sent me these two awesome movies
which i saw but a long time ago
mr brooks i didn't know about these and
glenn gary glenron oh yeah that's a
great movie yeah i know i really like
both of these movies i remember seeing
like mr brooks a long time ago i
remember liking that a lot yeah kevin
leads the glengarry leads
[Laughter]
yeah so we're gonna
watch those later yeah what they call
the glengarry leads isn't that yeah yeah
yeah that they were fighting it's been a
long time give them good leads they
[ __ ] keep the [ __ ] leads
for the salesman it's exactly
exactly like the way a lot of that [ __ ]
was yeah we'll have to watch those and
also we gotta watch um the elephant man
because that's gonna be the next movie
retrospective
that we're doing yeah cause uh
we're
yeah that was what won in the poll
this week by
a pretty large margin and i'm excited
because you know
uh zach says i like how the office looks
with minimalism
i don't it weirds me out like every time
i see
you know when i go to like uh edit the
videos and every time i see like the
little screen caps and stuff i'm like oh
that looks so [ __ ] weird i'm just so
used to there being like all these books
and things i'm just asking what you got
for your birthday
from me
um i know this is gonna sound [ __ ]
this is gonna sound bad i gotta wish you
wanted
you gotta be an exercise bike but that's
what i asked for that's what i asked for
well because i used to have an exercise
bike a long time ago and i really really
liked it and i used it every day and i
just never and then it broke because i
used it so much and i never got another
one and i was like man i should really
get another one and i had it on my um on
my amazon shopping list and i kept
meeting to buy it and i was just like i
can't really afford it this month oh i
can't really afford it this month and
then finally i said something about it
because you know in the new house we
have like a spare room and i was like
he's like oh we should make that a gym
he can put his weights and stuff in
there and then he's like and i was like
oh maybe i should get that exercise bike
now we could put that in there too and
he's like you want me to get it for you
for your birthday and i was like yeah
that would be good so yeah i'm gonna
work out an exercise bike a little
weight bench yeah actually it gets
delivered tomorrow yeah okay so that's
another reason i have to be that i have
a bunch more [ __ ] like coming to the
house too holy crap tomorrow i have to
go over there i have to put up
well i have to put two more desks
together you put together my bookshelves
and the one desk but i have two more
desks i have to put together and i have
to i got my new um woody columns
uh the things for the curtain
rod the brackets brackets uh i had to
order new brackets because the curtain
rod i came with like it only had one so
i had to order some more brackets so
they came yesterday so i gotta hang
curtains tomorrow
but the painting is done right the
office is painted and the bathroom is
painted we might paint some more [ __ ]
later but we're not really doing it
right now
the office could the the bathroom could
use a couple little touches well i'll
probably touch it up tomorrow yeah but
i mean it'd be like one roll of a
painter
yeah one roller i'll just roll around
with the wrong
places yeah it's going to be really cool
in there like i said i'm going to do
the office is just going to be a general
like gothic horror
type thing like usual but the bathroom
i'm doing like a
like a
art nouveau theme so i did kind of the
walls are kind of like this absinthe
green
and i got like a really cool
like alphonse mucha
shower curtain although it hasn't come
yet it's not coming till october 5th but
i got all the other [ __ ] i got like a
bunch of prints and stuff and put on the
walls it's going to look awesome
we have them
running around tom took me out to lunch
today yeah and then we just had a bud we
didn't really do anything exciting
though we just had a bunch of errands to
run really
had to go to the print shop how to go to
the post office i go to the bank
there's too much work that we have to do
they have the deadlines we got to do
we gotta uh
do shirts for a concert
yeah and we read 100 shirts
yeah well it's 80 yeah it's 80 something
shirts 81 shirts yeah
basically yeah so i got the
transparencies done today so we have to
shoot the screens and then we have so we
only have like two weeks we only have
like two weeks to do it i thought that
was less than that that was more like a
week
well uh the festival is not this weekend
but it's the following weekend okay yeah
right yeah
yeah so yeah so we don't know how long
to do it but we're kind of hoping to get
them done by next next
weekend yeah because if we get the
screen shot like tomorrow or tuesday
then we can just do them in batches
because i have to order some shirts too
we still have some in our thing
zach says would you ever paint a room
completely black well the office uh in
the new house is almost black it's like
a really dark
well it's a really dark gray but
probably on camera it's just gonna look
black
it's it i think it was when i looked up
the paints it said that it was under
grays maybe but it looked lighter than
some of the other blacks but then i put
it on the wall i was like oh that's
essentially black and that's i'm all
right with that
beezness says how much is it a pain to
carry stuff upstairs oh yeah it's a big
pain well
i don't know it's like i
always kind of wanted a house with an
upstairs i very very rarely
i think the only time i lived in a house
with upstairs was
when i was a kid and we had a townhouse
for a little while that had an upstairs
and i really liked that
but the only thing that sucks about it
is yeah carrying everything upstairs
but
a bunch of them
yeah most of the stuff um
i kind of feel like the only big thing
that still has to go upstairs is the bed
right i think most of the other stuff is
up there
yeah like all the hit all the heavy
boxes because all my heavy [ __ ] is up
there already
and i don't think i ordered any more
heavy furniture that needs to be carried
up there
so
hopefully it won't be
won't be too bad
zach says yeah it's light black
no need for me too says can't stay but
happy birthday jenny thank you and
congrats on the new place glad it worked
out shout out to the chat miss you guys
yeah
well you know
i just like i said i kind of just wanted
to drop by this i feel you know what it
feels weird i guess it doesn't feel like
my birthday today because i didn't even
have any cake well the thing is we went
out to lunch and i was kind of like
gonna get cake and i was like well man
i'm gonna get some cheesecake and then
like by the time i was finished eating i
was like i'm not gonna get
i don't know i just i feel like i'm used
to eating smaller meals so when i go out
to like to a restaurant meal and they
give you like
the the size of an american restaurant
meal i'm always just kind of like
it wasn't it wasn't a normal birthday i
mean this it fell right in the middle of
a goddamn move
and we've been [ __ ] and we didn't
really expect that to happen because
yeah i mean when you think about it i
was thinking about this the other day
because um
honestly we just you know the landlord
just came what like a week or two ago
and basically was like yeah you guys
have to move you're right so we moved to
this place and we're looking like yeah
okay
so it just kind of came out of nowhere
nowhere i couldn't plan anything not
really we just kind of had to get all
this [ __ ]
we've been together [ __ ] solid for
[ __ ]
a week
yeah running running just going back and
forth and forth running stuff right
i mean we even took a small load today
like we took some stuff out of the
garage
and because so you have to go there and
there's no sense of going there without
taking stuff so yeah i mean if you're
gonna make the trip i mean it's not
hugely far but it's far enough
um
to where it takes up you know it takes
like 20 minutes 30 minutes like to drive
there so it's like you might as well
throw some [ __ ] in your car while you're
going you got a digital slice of cake
thank you david yeah here's some digital
cake yeah i finally sent your shirt
today david yeah we just sent that out
we had to go do runs
uh we had to go to the
post office and had to go to the
printers
yeah get those transparencies
man i hope those shirts come out good
you know the image was small a lot
smaller than i thought it was going to
be there's three different ones
yeah smaller than the last image
well if i need to do another
transparency i'll do another
transparency we'll hold one up to the
shirt it's like it's not that big a deal
they're cheap they're only 75 cents yeah
but you have to do a um
i know but
just don't shoot a screen until we've
held one up too because it's hard for me
to judge because i can't look small to
me see it you know what i mean
uh mike cohe says take into account
murphy's law everything that can go
wrong
with plan ahead yeah
it's just i don't know it's
i don't i don't know i don't really mind
that much honestly i i would rather are
we be in the new house by halloween then
because my birthday is like not really
that big a deal i guess
what do you mean well i just well i
didn't want it to happen in the middle
of halloween so i missed halloween
halloween to me is a bigger deal than
like my birthday is i actually try to
ignore birthdays i [ __ ] i don't even
want to know now
[Laughter]
i don't even want to know
yeah he doesn't even like to be reminded
no i want to know how old i am
i just i i we didn't even do that much
for your birthday last time did we i
just i got you a cake
and i got you a card and then something
like that maybe something yeah and maybe
like a present and that was about it
right we didn't even really we didn't do
anything really
no i didn't want to know
[Laughter]
yeah once you get to a certain area
just like oh [ __ ] that
business the only thing i have left at
my old apartment is clean a little have
to turn my key in friday yeah that's
gonna be another thing once we get
everything
out of here i got to tear this [ __ ]
[ __ ] down once the show's over oh yeah
that's right yeah i got to break up this
[ __ ] thing this desk i mean i still
need this computer here like because i
got some [ __ ] i got to upload tomorrow
but i don't think i need the desk
anymore because we're not going to
stream from here anymore and i
recorded everything that i need to
record
and hopefully everything should come out
of here yeah hopefully i'll get
everything set up at the new place yeah
i don't know like i said i don't know if
i'll take my computer small probably
take the computers over on tuesday and
set everything up so i can make sure
that the internet's up and
stuff like that yeah tammy said that's
it celebrate twice as hard on halloween
yeah that's probably what i'll do i'll
just do like jenny's birthday a month
later and also it's halloween i kind of
like
one thing like you know what mannequins
did last night
they had a um
they had a theme tonight i only know
because i make i make the posters they
had a great idea they did because it's
like a month before halloween they did a
cheap ass
halloween trick-or-treat night so you're
supposed to come in like the most janky
ass halloween costume like from the
dollar store
and then like they gave prizes for the
worst ones i haven't seen any pictures
from it yet but i bet it was probably
pretty fun i was just like you know it
would have been nice to go but it's just
kind of like god
well it's moving and i'm so tired and
i'm so broke and
we have a million [ __ ] things to do
and
yeah you know what i mean but uh you
know it sounds like i'm complaining but
i'm actually like complaining well no
it's i'm really actually really excited
i'm excited about the new house it's
just a lot of work i didn't i forgot
that bee's nest is move at the same time
then his cat ran away during the move i
guess the cat got scared man of the new
apartment and [ __ ] ran see that's
what's kind of like freaking me out
about pookie she just
i don't know there's a different
situation it was an apartment that's
true
today when we were in he never found
that cat that cat tried to come back i
know you saw it
it's out of the parking lot
underneath the cars
it's only that's the only place that cat
could have gone
man that's like that's so sad that
cat'll come back probably
sometimes they do come back like after a
long time yeah
today when we were at the new house and
i was taken out because you know the
garbage goes out tomorrow morning
so i was taking out like all the old
boxes and all the trash and stuff then i
noticed that our neighbor had a couple
of dogs and i said oh that'll probably
keep pookie in line cause she'll go out
on the back porch and then just be like
uh oh puppies she'll like run back
inside when they bark at her
because that happened when i was uh
last june when i was on in saint
augustine remember you messaged me and
said that dog kind of ran after her
yeah the cat never came back yet so
that's so sad oh
if you go out and look for it you'll
probably find it thank you dom the bomb
it's in that area
i mean i would hope so they don't go far
well they have territory maybe it's
right i don't know how far you moved
away it might be trying to walk back to
the old house
okay if they can home i don't know
how far that would be
i've heard of animals doing 100 miles
yeah i've heard of animals doing that
well because they go by smell right and
like cats have a really good sense of
smell too just like dogs they got
geo-location
i always wondered about that yeah
i wish i i wish i'd got some of that
[Laughter]
i think they must have something in
their inner ear that allows them to
[ __ ] know which how
how far they went in a certain direction
yeah
yeah something like little magnet little
particles that are magnetic or something
i've heard that like they've speculated
that maybe like some birds and stuff
have that kind of stuff
i see i always i always wish i had that
because my sense of direction is just is
terrible and always has been
and it's it's so frustrating like i get
i get turned around really easy
seriously we've been going back and
forth to the new house like for
for more than a week now like sometimes
a couple times a day and i still like
kind of i put the gps on like it makes
me feel better even though i'm pretty
sure i know where i'm going it's just
because
between here in the new house they're
doing all of this road work right
they're building this new highway
and then like the old road is like way
down here and they're putting in all
these traffic circles
and they're working on it every day so
sometimes the traffic circles are open
and sometimes they're not open so it's
like i'm not really sure and then like
you have to come out and you have to be
rerouted like u-turn and i can't
remember where the u-turn is so i always
just feel better having the gps on even
though i pretty much know where i'm
going just because i don't know i get
lost really easily and even with the gps
sometimes i still get lost
yeah i don't understand it should get
lost
yeah i mean i'm an old army scout so
well like i said it's not it's it's more
it's probably more frustrating for me
than it is for you because it's like it
just makes me so so angry and i'm just
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with my
brain why doesn't it work like sure like
it works and it works good in other ways
but for some reason i'll try to go where
i know that i have to go and show like
wait no it's not here it's that way and
i'm like no
[Laughter]
no it's that way is it no it's not
just
because i don't know it's just it's
obvious to me there's nobody just no way
to explain it well like i said i've
always been really frustrated because
some people don't really seem to have
problems with that and i always had
problems with it it's some kind of
geolocation like i said it's just some
kind of innate instinct
that i have yeah it's not just me other
guys have it
it gets it get you
let army land navigation courses like
you know when you're going through
ranger school and [ __ ] [ __ ] rip
and and recondo they they all [ __ ]
weed out who can do that and who can't
for some reason i just
know what direction it is
and how far
you do by things called pace count
how many
you know how many steps does it normally
take you to cut to cover [ __ ] 100
meters or 25 meters
i used to know it all by heart but then
eventually it just kind of becomes kind
of like instinct you know how far you've
walked in kilometers
but then
the land now of course would be super
super [ __ ] hard it's nothing just a
piece of paper and a map and a compass
and you start off at a [ __ ] pole that
might have the name 20. they say your
starting pole is 20 and it goes you know
shoot at azimuth or [ __ ] one one
azimuth 135 for [ __ ] 50 for for like
1
600 meters
so you go okay 1.6 clicks
so then you walk in that direction
and you and off to your right and left
you're passing poles with numbers on
them and it says you got to write down
that number of the pole where that
target is there's gonna be a pole with a
number all right along that azimuth
[ __ ] 1600 meters
well when you get
you go okay i'm coming up on it it's
about 200 meters from here you know you
can't see your trees you know on the way
and then all of a sudden you're going
like
according to my pace count it's only 25
meters and all of a sudden you hit a
pole
and it's got a number might say 15 on it
and do you write that down you don't
know that it doesn't really feel like
i've gone far enough so you can walk
another 25 meters and there'll be
another one there
and then you go
is this is this it
and he goes maybe i didn't walk far
enough so you can walk to another 25
meters you see with another pole
so you have to be accurate
you know what i mean yeah which one was
it because they're testing your pace
count and you go i think it was the
second pole
so you put that down
and then the next problem will be shoot
at azimuth of [ __ ]
35 degrees and walk [ __ ] 500 meters
well if you get one of them wrong you
get all of them wrong because it's
bouncing you from one pole to the next
you know what i'm talking about yeah
anytime you hit and so sometimes you'll
go wait now this one couldn't be right
because there's no target here so that
last one must have been wrong which one
was it so you had to run all the way
back to the pole and goes i'm going to
start over let me put it
but you're doing it it's timed though
yeah and you might have to find six
poles in that day and that you might
have walked [ __ ]
seven miles we've all had to find six
poles in one day yeah if i'd say you
know it's like seven miles walking
around that's all that [ __ ] scout and
ranger [ __ ]
you gotta learn how to do it [ __ ] see i
don't know if they teach that [ __ ]
anymore because i think they give
everybody a gps now
but yeah that's like old school [ __ ]
there was no idea
well we had them they called them
sluggers
the [ __ ] was that big
and they weighed a lot
and that was our version of a gps back
then back in the 90s
the problem is is that they don't want
to know whether or not you can use a gps
anybody can use that they want to know
if you're [ __ ] talented if you can do
without it that's what they want to know
are you a [ __ ] geronimo [ __ ]
that they can just let go like [ __ ]
last of the mohicans and you can find
your way around you know
in the woods just with a compass and a
map
or in some cases no map just a compass
and a [ __ ] worksheet
so
i don't know all this [ __ ] about getting
lost in cities no
just doesn't happen
one says what flavor is that drink jenny
it's orange juice and what kind of vodka
is it uh whipped cream whipped cream
vodka so it's a creamsicle essentially
um yeah janet pirate says i always get
turned around and lost no sense of
direction at all yeah same here and like
i said it's very very frustrating
because like i said my brain works
pretty well in other ways but for
whatever reason it just doesn't work
right in that direction it really makes
me mad
that if your old apartment was only
three miles go back to the old your old
apartment and see if she's hanging out
there yeah bishop says my cat is scared
of people it doesn't matter yeah slipped
down there in the middle of the night
like a ninja yeah only moving it's only
three miles away i bet you she's back at
her old house
i mean i hope so that would make me
really sad like if you know it always
makes me sad when she knows she moved
she probably tried to go back in that
direction
go back home pookie is kind of like
she's scared of people when they first
come in like if we have friends come
over
she'll be like [ __ ] this and she runs
under the bed and like looks at them
with her big eyes like from under the
bed but if they're there and they hang
out and they're cool then she'll kind of
like scooch out and then she'll come
over and check them out beijing doesn't
have that beijing will immediately be
like hey i'm gonna come rub on your
stuff okay
like pretty much from immediately it's
weird because pookie is like
she's never had anything bad happen to
her i mean she's lived with us for
forever and she hasn't really been
scared of anything but man every time
the garbage truck goes by every time
somebody rings the doorbell she's like
[ __ ] no
and like runs under the bed now if it's
only three miles he says he goes back in
a couple days throwing three miles i'd
go back there at night
i bet you should be go out there with a
flashlight and look for eyes
i hope so she's probably out she's
probably back at the old house already
tom de bomb said tom what are your plans
for your new studio i don't know no
plans yet
i too worried about too many other
things right now he put like uh
he's he's been putting like all his army
stuff in there and yeah just in the
closet it's a man cave and [ __ ] it's
going to be a man cave yeah it's going
to have all kinds of paramilitary
[ __ ] gear and [ __ ] he was saying
that in the gym
yeah uh where he wants to put
he wants to make it look like a gym i
said are you gonna put like a bunch of
posters of arnold schwarzenegger up
there yeah are you gonna kiss him like
put lipstick on and kiss him no we can
put that we can put conan in there you
said yeah you said we could do like
frank for that
that'd be cool yeah like more of that
[ __ ]
it's like that's some [ __ ]
growth you know what i mean
i want that one where
on canvas
which i think it just says barbarian i
think that one's called barbarian right
there that's another yeah i think that's
just called the barbarians
call where he's just sitting there on
death dealer remember death dealer oh
yeah
that's a pretty famous yeah yeah yeah i
remember that that's the very favorite
also wouldn't mind getting the one with
the with the badass [ __ ] on the
sleigh being pulled by polar bears and
you gotta be the [ __ ] if you got a sled
up in the snow pulled by polar bears
anybody wear any clothes
i don't get cold too big to get cold
i'm too jacked to get cold i don't even
need to coat all the muscles keeping me
warm yeah
no man [ __ ]
his caloric requirements on a daily
level are so [ __ ]
steep you know he requires so so much
so much protein per day
that he generates heat he doesn't even
need clothes he's not even not even in
the [ __ ] way and even people could
like stand
next to him just for one like he was a
fire yeah
that's where he heat the whole house up
just pure testosterone
[ __ ] heat the house just plug him
into the wall he's just gonna we don't
have to pay a heating bill you just have
to you just have to like feed him some
[ __ ] raw eggs and some chicken
breasts and stuff
david june says tom's new show don't
cross the ross
that's a good title actually i think you
should you should call it that you see i
want a show where i talk a lot of [ __ ]
on it right but
it can't be so much that i get [ __ ]
um
banned
oh and just they shut my show down or
the [ __ ] cops come after me or some
[ __ ] like that what are you planning on
saying that are gonna have the cops
after you i don't know man there's no
telling what you can and can't get away
with nowadays
i don't know i was just reading about um
our next week's topic friday night's
topic which is gonna be elliot roger and
the
and the thing about that you know just a
little uh teaser is that his parents
like the [ __ ] that he was saying on
youtube and stuff was scary enough for
his parents to call the cops but the
cops didn't do anything yeah so well
they just looked at that dude like i had
doing then
yeah well he did spoilers
so you know you can't ever do not he
wasn't physically imposing or anything
no but you don't need to be
i mean he didn't need to be obviously
because he just shot people and hit
people with his car
so there's a [ __ ] ton of dudes that look
like that that talk like that they never
do anything i know but that's the thing
that you well i know that but
you can't tell
dudes that
look and act like that and who are kind
of like that there's lots of them most
of them don't do anything
yeah but you know there's a lot of dudes
that are actually serial killers but
they don't ever do it
that's you know we talked about that on
the show yeah we have talked about that
too that it's like people think about
well the thing about it is that it's all
kind of on a on a spectrum isn't it
because it's like everybody's been in a
frustrating situation like man i could
kill that [ __ ] right now right
but it's like you know 99.99 people
aren't gonna do it that's not quite the
same thing that i'm talking about no i
know what you're talking about
for every one of them
for every one of those deadness raiders
there's 20 of them
that haven't done anything but it's
that's they have that ideation that same
kind of dude and everything the same
fantasies that same kind of weird
perversion
it's just that they don't ever take that
leap they there's something in them that
stops them from doing it
um but they're
fantasizing about it but then they just
never do it
yeah that's kind of like uh it's kind of
scary to think about i guess yeah and
that was that that was that book written
by that fbi profiler that i read he said
a long time ago just for you know for
every one of those serial killers
there's at least 20 25 of them that
aren't doing it yeah it makes sense to
think about because it's not
you know i'm not gonna it's it's
unusual but it's not that unusual so you
are gonna have people that think about
[ __ ] but never do it yeah so you know
and they got too much as they use or
they have
they they can they have natural
inhibitions that will stop them from
doing it well and that's something else
we've talked about with serial killers
too we're always kind of like
speculating um somebody that had those
fantasies or ideations but they were
raised differently or they were like in
a different environment or a different
situation and they never ended up acting
on them you know what i mean i think a
lot of it is that they don't have the
physicality or the confidence
could be i think that's a lot of it
you know they're um
too shy
to actually [ __ ] do it and too
physically weak to do it so they just
don't ever do it they're afraid they're
gonna get afraid that they'll get caught
afraid that they that they'll be
overpowered by the victim
which some of them might might be that
weak it is a weakness
you know it is not a strength to do that
[ __ ]
i always kind of well the thing about it
too is that like you said i think to
actually do it you have to have some
kind of weird
i don't even know if i'd call it
confidence but you have to have some
kind of like
thing where you think you're too smart
to get caught or
something i think i think i would call
it confidence
yeah well it's just yeah i'm just saying
that usually confidence is seen as a
good thing but in that situation i don't
think it's a very well think of it like
a jumping out an airplane yeah you know
what i mean or or you know the
confidence you need to say like going to
combat or something or the confidence
you need to actually shoplift or the
confidence you need to actually rob a
bank that you need a confidence for it
yeah you have to have a certain amount
of self-esteem i can do it that kind of
[ __ ] thing you know
and
no that some of those dudes are so
losers that so much they're losers you
know even the ones that actually do do
it are losers well yeah
but some of them are so so much of
losers that they can't
they don't have the confidence to
actually do it
or the physicality to do it
there's some dudes that look at look at
gary ridgeway he could barely do it
barely he was a small weak man he killed
a lot of people
he got the jump on them and they were
women and they were and they were much
smaller than him gary ridgeway could
have got his ass whipped by a lot of
women there are a lot of women out there
that would whip his ass
yeah all right some gym rat girls
would [ __ ] give me a run for my money
weigh a similar amount
now
they're on peds you know what i mean
performance enhancing drugs a lot of
them uh but no there are gym rat girls
that would have [ __ ] gary ridgeway up
because he wasn't physically fit at all
yeah he was just a little scrawny
prepper pov says i don't see how elliot
wasn't overpowered when he was killing
three other guys in his apartment with a
knife they think that he well he didn't
do them all at once i don't think and i
think he just ambushed him one at a time
like as they came home and then
tried to like clean it up and hide it
that's is
that's from what i remember so it's not
like
you know so it's not like three dudes
jumped him like and he ninja sometimes
dudes like that use a ruse
they talking to him they're talking he's
they're talking to the victim they tell
the victim somebody well he knew them
they were his roommates yeah and they
turned you know they're they're not
their guard isn't up they turn their
back and he [ __ ] stabs them dabs them
in the back
yeah i kind of feel like it was probably
something more like that and like a
confrontation type situation
yeah he was probably like
because he had been planning this for a
while you know what i mean like his
little [ __ ] i don't want to um
yeah don't spoil the [ __ ] i won't spoil
the show well like i said i don't i i
remember some of the stuff about the
case and i like kind of wrote some notes
about it like earlier but i just like
skimmed through them real quick so i
don't remember like all the little
details but i do remember that um they
think that he did that like one at a
time
um let's see what else stop prop happy
birthday jenny love y'all hey i'm good
everybody's here
celebrating my birthday with me like i
said
i wish i kind of wish i had some cake
but i don't really want to eat cake
is that weird
yeah
yeah
last night i started watching for some
reason i have like this strange
fascination with they have all these
like like baking competition shows
particularly like the dessert ones i'm
still waiting for what's that one called
sugar rush
and i'm kind of waiting for the next
season because they always do a
halloween one the christmas one's pretty
good too but the halloween one obviously
that's my jam so i'm waiting for that
one to come out but i found this other
show last night while i was scrolling
through netflix called what the [ __ ] is
it called bake squad
and basically it's four
um
bakers that are like actual like good
bakers like they do it for a living
and they every show they always have
like a challenge like somebody's i'm
having a party for my dad's 60th
birthday and he likes this that the
other so each one of them does
like a big huge fancy dessert and they
have seven hours so
it's not like one of those ones where
it's like they only have three hours so
everything's kind of like they don't
have time to like do anything good uh
and then like the person picks it at the
end for some reason i'm like fascinated
by shows like that mr roboto says old
man serial killer has nothing to lose uh
chen there's usually aren't any old man
serial killers
um
serial k serial killing is like uh
that's a young man
it's directly connected to the sex drive
after they hit andreano pause and the
[ __ ] they go into the damn middle age
phase their sex drive [ __ ]
tapers off i mean those dudes aren't on
[ __ ] peds they're not [ __ ] doing
trt they don't think about that or they
didn't well don't give them any ideas so
their sex drive goes away what happens
is still like serial killers how many
serial killers do you think are going to
like trt clinics because they just want
to keep seeing that you're killing the
game i gotta get back in the game yeah
like it's just like that book i reviewed
like not too long if you guys watch my
book reviews um i read this book called
larry and it was about exactly that it
was about like a jason style yeah killer
like serial killer who loved to kill
like you know co-eds
and he was like old now he's like 60
something and he lives with this like
gross old mom and he's just kind of like
i gotta get back in the thing and he's
just like all cringed he's like guys
they're running i can't you know it's
like it's super super funny
i really really like that book a lot
it's hilarious thank you mr roboto
serial killing is a [ __ ] um serial
killing is not confidence it's brain
type and psychology yeah it's you know
like i said there's there's kind of like
a lot of combination like a combination
of a lot of things like i said yeah you
have to have confidence to do anything
without confidence there's nothing
and that's part of the [ __ ]
drives
yeah i'm saying there's a lot of guys
that have that ideation but they don't
do it they don't have the confidence to
do it
yeah like you know like they said they
know it they don't do it or they get
their asses whipped well that's probably
the only reason i never robbed a bank i
don't don't think i haven't thought
about it there's a lot of people that
are like that
i don't think i have that
just one time and i'd have all the money
i wanted serial murderer is
serial killing is sexual and uh it is a
it is a sexual orientation
so
when the sex drive is gone the killing
goes away and everybody tell you that
yeah largely you don't see too many like
80 year olds toddling around with a
cane i'm not interested
and
they get sick of it they they call it
called they burn out that's what they
call it they get sick of it's the same
but it's if you look at it it's
adrenopause
yep testosterone makes people
evil
it may not be testosterone who knows i
mean i already talked about that
camp guy said my wife watches the
british baking show i also like i like
that too i've watched it off and on i
had this theory
while we were doing one of the shows
as i was learning about looking you know
biochemistry and [ __ ]
performance-enhancing drugs and [ __ ]
trt and testosterone and how it works
anabolic steroids
there are some guys who are totally
normal
who've messed with okay
let me explain something
in
in humans well actually in all animals
male and female
the main anabolic
compound
that causes healing
in the body and
in both males and females is
testosterone
is your body's ability to heal up
you know after damage
science comes in and says well maybe we
can
make something better than that
all right that can go into those
receptors and actually cause more
healing we call those steroids and
there's six to 20 times more powerful
than testosterone
and they go into the receptors that
[ __ ] test out that
testosterone goes into the molecule
looks a lot like it the compound looks a
lot like testosterone but it's improved
they've been making them since you know
the 30s really 40s
some totally normal dudes have taken
awful strange
anabolic steroids and it's really [ __ ]
up their sexuality one of the ones that
really has it notorious is one called
trend balloon
trend below
some guys it actually causes them to
attack women physically
rage you know they see a woman she's
attractive so he'll want to attack her
and then he has to stop himself or other
people stop him
um
weird sexual fantasies uh they start
going getting into porn that they
normally wouldn't get into they start
[ __ ] uh turn some [ __ ]
bisexual tri-sexual gay whatever it
a [ __ ]
their sexuality can get kind of [ __ ]
twisted
on trend
what if
serial killers have some kind of a
problem
in the gonadal problem where they
produce testosterone but the molecule is
kind of [ __ ] in error in other words
it's a mutant version of testosterone
that looks a little bit more like trend
bologne and causes like a mind-altering
uh
property which would make you violent
i'm interested if you find some of these
violent serial killers can they [ __ ]
do a blood test isolate their
[ __ ] testosterone and compare it to
normal testosterone maybe there's a
difference
maybe there's just a slight molecular
difference in the testosterone that he's
making
yeah it could be i don't know if
anybody's uh done that research or not
i'd have to look it up maybe he's maybe
something closer to look like tren
i mean i know they've done research um
you know that says that a lot of people
a lot of uh men that are serial killers
have
lowered inhibitions and things of that
nature like stuff in their frontal lobes
but i don't know if they've done
anything with like hormonal stuff i bet
you their hormones are not quite the
same that's what i'm thinking
because there's a lot of variations in
in the body and you know maybe he has a
slightly
uh uh
mutant
[ __ ]
cells
in the in his gonads that instead of
producing normal testosterone it might
be something closer to a
performance-enhancing drug like test
like trenbolone which would make you
violent
and have weird sadism and [ __ ] they had
one dude he was you can you can go on it
there's a [ __ ] show called more
plates more dates and [ __ ] the name
of the show was [ __ ] tremblone
um
some about
16 year old on trenbolone
something about sex bots once anyway
this this kid started he was taking
trend when he was in high school it made
him [ __ ] crazy and he got obsessed
with this idea of making sex robots and
he even made a whole damn
diagram of how they would work and
everything and he was crazy of course
drove him crazy until it wore off
and he he tells the story about it
and uh turned you into a [ __ ]
psychopath
it doesn't do it to everybody great like
we need any more of those
well it doesn't do it doesn't do that to
everybody but it it it's
it does it to a lot of dudes to [ __ ]
make you [ __ ] crazy especially at
high doses
and you know they want to put on [ __ ]
30 pounds 20 pounds of muscle in two
months
yeah the [ __ ] drastic change
drastic you know boom just in two months
another 25 pounds of muscle [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] crazy of course that's
going to be mind altering
yeah i mean that's some drastic [ __ ]
chemistry has to happen for for for the
body to respond to that strong that
quickly you know
that's [ __ ] insane
and it can't that can't be good for you
oh i'm sure no way
no way danny rolling ghostface had made
a very funny comment and it's been it's
gone now but he was talking about how
old people serial killers maybe they go
the route of uh the mass vehicular
manslaughter by like driving through
people and just saying i don't know what
happened
i will tell you like i used to live when
i lived with my grandmother
a long time ago and she had um right
behind her house that was like a 7-11
and um
i swear the time that i lived there
which is a few years we had at least
four old people drive through the front
of that 7-eleven and they all said the
same thing it's like oh they thought
they were hitting the brake and not the
gas they didn't kill anybody thankfully
but
that [ __ ] it got to a point where it
was like a joke it's just they couldn't
[ __ ] stop but yeah if you think about
it if an old person wanted to be a
serial killer they could just drive
around in their car and just be like
[ __ ] you people
then they'd be like i don't know what
happened i just i hit the gas instead of
the break i'm old give me a break if we
watch the alvarez i haven't yet but i've
heard been i've heard about that maybe
we can watch it tonight
beezness says i have the dennis raider
line of lingerie oh my god
somebody should make that well should
they no probably not although
it's the 21st century has someone made
that probably
and i'm sure someone would buy it too
because i kind of feel like
serial killer memorabilia is like kind
of a big uh kind of a big seller
remember back in the old days i think
god this was like back in the maybe the
late 80s or the early 90s
somebody had um
they started making a like a playing
card deck
and it was all serial killers and i
remember like there was a huge
um you know outcry about about it like
how tacky it was and stuff but
i was like little do people know how
much worse that we get i can just like
pretty much sell anything with serial
killers on it and people will buy it
camp guy i was pressing on the break as
hard as i could
october is asking me about uh
asking me what i think of the movie five
million
five million years to earth
and is it so hard to find i don't know
what he's talking about
i've heard of that but i haven't i've
never heard of it mr roboto says is
building sex robots really that crazy
tom
seems like a hobby well you got to see
that you got to see is this honestly
yeah it doesn't really seem all that
crazy i mean as far as hobbies go that's
not they're gonna hurt anybody no he but
he wrote it down he wrote down how they
worked and what they were supposed to
say it's [ __ ] crazy it's real crazy
and i think it was just a
head oh he was going to the ted bundy
buddy all i need is the whole
head yeah he didn't need tits or
no
anything you have to you have to watch
it yourself that's that's on that other
channel i'm not going to watch that a
long time since i've
there was more to it than that it was
just
it was weird
his
his fantasizing about making these sex
robots he's in high school when he's
doing this
kind of like along the lines of
something that a serial killer would
fantasize about
hmm
you know what i mean
like seeing how serial killers always
trying to construct some kind of altar
or some kind of [ __ ] perfect sex or
like btk was doing he was like trying he
was gonna make that barn into like a sex
dungeon yeah whatever the [ __ ] he was
doing he had like all kind of plans that
stuff right
so
i'm all for having like an active
imagination and stuff but he was the
same dude that was attacking women
though yeah that's what i'm saying yeah
that's it he said he would attack him
but then right he'd attack him but then
as soon as he started he was doing it in
high school
he'd just reach up and grab someone
check by the throat and as soon as he
did it he'd [ __ ] you know jump off of
her and realize that oh man you know and
he said it made him real racist too
he'd be real racist against anybody
whether they were just another race
any race he'd be real racist against
them and then he'd regret it and then
he'd overcompensate by buying them food
and [ __ ] or buying another [ __ ]
person of another race and then
meanwhile every single person in this
high school is like what the [ __ ] is
wrong they were scared of him he's
[ __ ] huge
well i'd be scared of him too because
the dude is clearly not rational totally
out of his [ __ ] mind and it was trend
trend is notorious trend balloon
it's notorious for [ __ ] making you
nuts
and like i said we don't we don't
teenagers are already [ __ ] done we
don't need more of that and like i said
teenagers teenage boys are already the
worst it's like you don't really need to
like amplify that yeah honestly i had
brothers i'm just you know what i mean
although my brothers were actually
lovely they didn't go through any of
that crap
not really uh they were they were
actually pretty cool and they're still
pretty cool yeah dj maniac said those
were trading cards not playing cards but
yeah yeah that's right well i thought
that am i confusing it with
didn't the fbi at some point please
correct me if i'm wrong
didn't they in the 80s
there uh they had like a playing card
set that you could buy that had like all
the most wanted criminals on it because
they thought that it would help
like get the [ __ ] out into the public
and it would like help you know what i
mean um i could be just totally
remembering that wrong but i thought
that was something they did back in the
day so i think i was confusing that with
the serial killer training
i remember the us army came out with a
[ __ ] playing card with all the
[ __ ] top brass of [ __ ]
uh saddam's saddam hussein's government
i remember that in the first gulf war
they came out with that remember that
yeah i remember that yeah i remember
they were issuing about all the troops
and [ __ ]
but you know what i bet you that deck is
worth a lot of money now
oh i'm sure like if you have it it's
probably yeah because some collectors
would like pay tons of money for that i
would like that i would like to have a
cup a deck of the from the first i was i
was in service during that war i didn't
get sent to that theater i got sent to
the dmz in korea
but we lived that [ __ ] war through
the korean side man looking because
there was [ __ ] going on there too
guys that all caught up and stopped lost
they couldn't get out of the army
because the [ __ ] they didn't want the
army to go under they were pissed off
they're i'm supposed to be out of the
army by now
you know it was all kinds of weird well
that's gotta suck if you just went in
for a certain amount of time and they're
like oh yeah guess what you can't go
home now and then be like yeah [ __ ] that
yeah some dudes got extended [ __ ]
three four or five months
you know on you know extra [ __ ]
extensions on the end of their on their
yeah i remember hearing about that that
was like pretty common and everybody was
getting like really yeah
pepper pov said there are dudes in new
york city who will walk around trying to
sell you trading cards with porn stars
on them
that's pretty good that's a good idea
that's actually a good idea yeah i could
make one of those yep well you need
permission obviously
um so they're talking about john wayne
gacy and how he was often blackout drunk
when he killed and also uh jeffrey
dahmer was too i think yeah maybe they
had to like drink alcohol to like give
them like you said give them like the
confidence to do the [ __ ] or reduce
inhibitions yeah well same kind of thing
yeah
a schwarzkopf rookie card he's 63.
uh did dahmer black out when he ate his
victims i'm not was he blacked out i
don't know it's hard to say because
he he was an alcoholic i mean jeffrey
dahmer
he started like bringing booze to school
when he was in high school right
like he would uh he would bring in like
booze and a thermos and stuff so he was
drinking then so i don't know if he was
blackout drunk when he did this stuff so
he didn't like remember
as a general rule of thumb don't believe
anything the serial killer says
yeah that too it's just
liars yeah
and they'll say well i don't remember i
was drunk that's because they don't want
to tell you the details
and and they'll they'll admit to certain
murders but then they'll deny other ones
and they know that they did that because
what because that girl was underage he
wants to deny i didn't do that one but
then you know
bundy did that well yeah because then he
killed that 12 year old girl killed but
he wouldn't you know i didn't do that oh
that wasn't me that was immediately like
i admit to all the other ones
who were
but he didn't want to admit that he had
maybe he had some pedo tendencies well
it's just kind of like how a lot of
serial killers will freely admit to
killing people but necrophilia that's
just a little bit even though they know
they did it yeah
well wasn't bundy like that because he
didn't talk about running around with
the heads yeah he did some necrophilia
[ __ ] well i think that's why that's
maybe not as widely known as like
and why people still
um
you know kind of be like oh ted bundy
the sexy serial killer whatever the [ __ ]
um i'm like do people forget that he
actually like had sex with severed heads
and like kept them on his fireplace
metal because that's pretty [ __ ]
gross so
i
but you know
like i said pedophilia and necrophilia
it seems like they'll admit to other
stuff but not that which i get it but
in a way it's also like absurdly funny
to me that
like in a in a blackly humorous kind of
way that serial killers would
draw the line somewhere
they'll be like yeah i'll rape and
torture women and like cut them up and
everything but
i would never have sex with a dead body
i'm like oh that's where that's the hill
you're gonna die that's the line you're
gonna draw okay so you'll admit to other
stuff but not bad i don't know that's
just very funny to me
ah
what year in america did the drinking
age turn from 18 to 21.
then i went um yeah because it states
it's different it's um [ __ ] man in
louisiana i it happened
in florida i remember it happened in my
lifetime because i remember it happened
but i think it was sometime in the 70s
or maybe the 80s but i'd have to look it
up
yeah if i remember correctly
in louis in louisiana it didn't change
to 21 until
very late 80s
they held out a long time the feds were
punishing them by withholding a bunch of
federal funding funding for the roads
to help them with the roads louisiana
didn't care
that's a
what was it was that pokey yeah she
jumped off she jumped down from the tree
bam
yeah
they eventually uh went along with it
though
which i think it was stupid the only
reason why they did it is because of
drunk driving
yeah that's why they did it and it was a
it was kind of just a
it was a cultural phenomenon of those
times
in
the 60s and the 70s 50s 60s 70s
80s
people actually would drive around with
a drink in their hand drinking in the
south they did it quite a bit
it was nothing to see a dude driving by
with a beer in his hand drinking a beer
well
in the south teenagers all had access to
cars and trucks
and they had a cruising cult culture
where they would just drive around
because there's really nothing to do
yeah nothing else to do they would just
drive around and make loops over and
over again
going down through the main drag of
their little town everybody sitting on
the hoods of their cars
[ __ ] hooping and hollering and
drinking and [ __ ]
and uh some would get [ __ ] trashed so
the teenagers had a pretty high
mortality rate during that during that
phase of american
development
they were all drinking and they were all
[ __ ] driving and they were dying
so
they raised it to 21
unless you were in the military if
you're in the military
you could drink
but if you were a civilian you could you
could you could join the military at 18.
so if you're in the military you could
drink at 18.
not in public though only on a military
base
actually i think you could present
military id in any bar and they'd let
you but you had to be serving
they figured you know if you were going
to be serving the country then you had
the right to drink i mean [ __ ] world
war ii was being was fought by dudes who
were [ __ ] 17 18 you know yeah which
got a fire on german children and [ __ ]
so
um
so they [ __ ] raised it to and i think
it did save lives
during that era well yeah it did seem to
i mean i don't know the statistics off
hand but it did seem to yeah it was like
something amazing you know i mean like
80 of all the [ __ ] drunk driving
fatalities were all people under the age
of [ __ ] 21.
they were all [ __ ] teenagers well
yeah
but i think if you were to go ahead and
[ __ ] drop it back down to 18 in in in
the modern era here in the in the us it
probably wouldn't affect it much much
because that cruising small town
cruising culture is gone
and i think now like in the culture
nowadays people are not real
it's not like it was it's not like a
thing it's like oh let's go get [ __ ]
up and drive around that's just like not
something that a lot of people really do
anymore right um you know
like you said that's kind of like a
small town thing it was a small town
because it was nothing better to do yeah
uh you know so you just kind of
kind of like um
smallville from superman
you know there's nothing to do
yes usually like driving around getting
[ __ ] up during the age of internet and
internet dating and everything and
social media it's the the landscape has
changed a lot
also the speed at which people develop i
think is
in the way people develop is very
different
um
i think
i think pre
internet kids grew up faster
they developed social skills faster
everything was in your face it was
[ __ ] very much a dating culture
hanging out
they were good with that um
but they were [ __ ] they did [ __ ] in
excess
i think actually in some ways kids today
are a little bit smarter
i kind of feel like it too well because
back in the old it's like you didn't
really think about it like people did
dumb [ __ ] all the time yeah if it felt
good you did it it was kind of
hedonistic
so you're like yeah crack let's smoke
that
why not
it must be good
[Laughter]
yeah so yeah a lot more drugs back then
well yeah i mean i don't know i i kind
of feel like the drugs that are kind of
widespread nowadays aren't as [ __ ] up
maybe as the ones back then i don't know
i do kind of feel that's that's why i
don't like [ __ ] on people younger
because it's like one the culture is
completely different than when we grew
up but also like you said i think people
have more
i people seem more awareness their
awareness of a little bit better you
know of of the consequences
i would say those cell phones
in themselves and social media is the
drug of of their age they're constantly
on them
they're like kind of like almost
addicted to it but i can understand it
because it's real-time information and
contact with other people
what what
[ __ ] millennials and youngers do you
know we're we're [ __ ] gen x the way
they live
when we were kid would have been kids
would have been something
out of science fiction and it would have
been
portrayed in a negative light very
negative
we would have seen them as like what
star trek would call the borg
remember the board yeah
and [ __ ]
they they end up getting one of the
borgs and they cut off his [ __ ]
wireless internet so he couldn't talk to
the rest of the connective collective
and he was getting upset because he
couldn't hear his friends
remember that they're like what's wrong
with him because he's not in connection
with the borg hive mind and he can't
hear all the voices where is everybody
so he's losing it
[Laughter]
and he could because he couldn't be an
individual and that's kind of how
if you were to go back in time and
explain what was going on now with
social media and [ __ ]
wireless [ __ ] devices which were
something right out of [ __ ] star trek
than star trek the next
generation
people would have seen that as something
dangerous and like man that's not good
because which i can kind of understand
it
it's a two-edged sword parts of it are
really good parts of it are not that
good
because it's two ways they can watch you
corporations can fi it's not governments
it's corporations they're far more
dangerous than governments
um i think the corporations run all
these governments now there's some
soviet to it
and um
they're they're dangerous they don't
have their
corporations and businessmen and [ __ ]
have always basically wanted to take
over the world going all the way back to
the 1400s and 1300s and
a corporation can is a dictatorship and
it [ __ ] makes money
and in ancient times they had their own
armies their own courts they send its
people to death the east india company
and [ __ ] they go and crush other
countries that's still kind of happening
now but it's done in a different way big
tech and [ __ ]
online banking you can do all that [ __ ]
they're more powerful than they ever
were
um
man
what's going on now especially you know
[ __ ] the [ __ ] that big tech and some
of these corporations are doing
had we known about that back in the
[ __ ] star trek next generation
[ __ ]
earl late 80s early 90s era we've been
worried about it back then i'm kind of
worried about it now [ __ ] it's just
uh kind of like what it was named
general eisenhower said misplaced powers
what's what they call
he says uh the the
what's it called the [ __ ] military
industry the misplaced powers of the
[ __ ] military industrial complex
it's more like something on a damn blade
runner [ __ ] whalen [ __ ] yutani and
[ __ ]
tyrell corporation and
[ __ ] who are just kind of above
the law they just do whatever they want
with these [ __ ] powerful corporations
[ __ ] it's a threat threat to mankind
if yes me mr roboto asked uh were
mushrooms big in the old days
in the old days
the old days
they were around they were around i
don't know if it was i don't know in
when i was growing up i know people that
did them but i don't know if it was like
any bigger than any other type of thing
yeah they were around the
it's more common to see things like
[ __ ] acid window pain [ __ ] pain
yeah and things and [ __ ] what was
your little peyote [ __ ] pills and
[ __ ]
he's getting [ __ ] i kind of feel like
yeah and i feel like that was more in
the zeitgeist i wasn't like a big
druggie i didn't hang out with a big a
lot of druggies but mushrooms are kind
of not compact and they're kind of
[ __ ] it's like something that's like
something hippie would have yeah you got
some mushrooms man
oh my friend you picked them man
they're great
make 18 then we eat them it tastes like
[ __ ] man but you you'll
you know it's well that's the very best
kind of drugs because they're free yeah
they're free man somebody has a question
for you i was reading about the korean
war yeah and how koreans felt about
america after is it true that south
korea was that upset with us after the
korean war
uh no no
it would depend on who it is you're
talking to
when i was there [ __ ] old people
treated you treated
would treat me and other american
soldiers especially we'd be going
through their [ __ ] towns in the
middle of the night they'd come out and
treat you like a [ __ ] hero because
the korean the korean conflict on that
peninsula
was a civil war really
that
both uh the soviet union and the united
states were involved in we were involved
in their civil war all kinds of weird
[ __ ] happened between
who are now people who all this kind of
weird [ __ ] happened between the koreas
the north and south koreans
they divided slowly it was kind of
artificially but they divided slowly on
a cultural level
once they got divided up you know russia
demanded as part of their war
reparations that they should have the
north and that should be their security
sector and they put in
a public government and we put in our
public government
and that divided korea up
and uh but during all that stuff
when the first invasion happened
massacres happened
a lot of [ __ ] got hidden
um
a lot of people don't know still what
happened
um i mean neither side does they'll be
building something and they'll [ __ ]
dig and they'll find a [ __ ] place
where there'd be like
300 dead koreans
civilians buried in some area massacre
and nobody really knows what happened
somebody did it
well obviously somebody did it yeah
and uh some of the fighting didn't have
anything to do with uniformed armies
it was just civilian
koreans slaughtering each other in in
the middle of this [ __ ] war
based upon loyalties
to either
i guess you could say
i don't want to say between communism
and capitalism that was a [ __ ]
that is kind of a mainstream dichotomy
that they teach you
in some kind of history class that's not
really what it was
it was more along the lines of [ __ ]
koreans slaughtering each other based
upon were they loyal to the korean
civilization or not or disloyal to the
korean civilization and because korea
was always an independent civilization
you have to understand for thousands of
years they were caught between a rock
and a hard place
which was
the chinese empire were in the japanese
empire they were caught right in the
middle for thousands of years and it was
just this little place that was trying
they had their own language
their own breed of people they're the
most genetically homogeneous [ __ ]
population on the planet
and they fought for their own identity
and these two superpowers both treated
them as and considered them to be slaves
basically
they were fighting over as if they were
possessions
it was it's is korea is a fascinating
[ __ ] country and there are strong
people
and are very good looking people real
good looking when you go there um
they're unlike any other kind of
easterner
uh everything about them is is different
um like they're they don't even have an
eastern religion they're they're
christian
which you wouldn't expect that but they
they are
um now do they behave like christians no
not really
kind of feel like you're in the presence
of japanese people
kind of
but uh
no uh you're going to have different
opinions
about the the u.s involvement
in general
south koreans uh
saw
the old
united states as their protector
and i think rightly so
the north koreans are bad dude real bad
one of the worst regimes to have ever
existed
make the nazi regime look like child's
play
in every way
including the racism
north koreans are extreme xenophobia
extreme racism
cool kitty says very happy birthday to
you jenny thank you very much thomas and
gloria's bastard says the only mushrooms
i know is the portobello delicious
i even like those portobello burgers man
uh tom's and gloria's bastards then
asked tom what is your take on the hit
of the president from haiti what's the
end game
i didn't hear what he said what do you
say
what is your take on the hit of the
president from haiti what is the end
game
when did that happen yeah i heard
the president
i think i think that pokey yeah i don't
know anything about it i think i did
hear that what you doing little
some uh come here
president of haiti got [ __ ] killed
there's some kind of civil war going on
there but i know very little about it so
i don't really comment on things i don't
know what it is she's she's farting
around back then she does what is she
doing
she's running around i gotta go to the
bathroom
you talk to him you talk to like you got
another drink yeah you wanna be making
them well you gotta go back from the
bathroom
no i'm drinking my watery coffee
now dj managing south korea was probably
still terrified of america i don't
really understand what
i don't uh i don't know what you're
talking about
south korea and the united states were
basically allies from the very beginning
okay yeah the red chinese talking about
us uh a shooting war on their social
media
yeah the chinese uh the ccp is bad man
they're very bad
and uh they want taiwan back
and the united states is no longer
no longer really uh
negotiating from a place of power
so they're probably going to take
um
taiwan not to that taiwan uh yeah
yeah they're probably gonna take taiwan
back she's sticking her paw under the
door while i was in the bathroom
and a lot of people don't realize how
bad
china hates
japan they're still pissed over the
[ __ ] rape of nanjing and rape of nan
king here eric
and um
chinese social media is constantly
pumping that the united states has
collapsed and that china is now the
global superpower
and uh
that they're going to bring us to heal
that
we attacked them with a biological
weapon that failed
and that uh the that
china have now reserves the right to to
attack to attack us [ __ ] with with
biological weapons they then a couple
days back they uh called out um
george soros they called him uh
the most evil man on the planet he's a
destroyer of civilizations
and that they they're putting a hit out
on george soros
um and the thing is is that china
china set when what china says in its uh
state-run media sounds like something
that north korea would say it sounds
hyperbolic and insane
to western ears but they do not
understand easterners they are
absolutely serious absolutely
they say crazy [ __ ] because they [ __ ]
believe crazy [ __ ] and they'll do it
so they don't
they do kind of talk [ __ ] a bit but they
they do believe
their own
[ __ ]
um
we're on the verge of like another
world war
i don't think it'll be like world war ii
it will be like unlike any other global
conflict but uh it'll it'll be a lot
more high-tech
um
a lot more computerized
a lot more like economic and cyber
warfare
a lot of asymmetric [ __ ]
a lot of bio warfare
a lot of bribery and a lot of
infiltration where you pay traders to do
things for you in other countries
it's kind of like the the the the war
that uh
kind of like a [ __ ] war it's not an
open fighting war that will happen here
and there but it'll be [ __ ] like [ __ ]
do you know we should talk [ __ ] lie and
spin and steal let me go and make you
another drink
okay no it's not that one it's the other
one
no it's this one is it that's coffee oh
that's coffee okay i thought that was
see i know i know what i'm doing
yeah thank you
geez i'm not that drunk
all right so uh have the cats adapted to
the new house we have not taken them yet
so we'll see how that goes
uh thank you maddie p have you guys
watched midnight mass yet no but i
actually do want to see that that's the
new mike flanagan thing it's on netflix
and uh yeah i really want to see that
thank you so much cool kitty have a
drink or two on me well thank you i will
yeah i heard midnight mess is good it's
i've
tried to kind of avoid like i said but
every now i think i was on av club today
and i saw like a headline about it and
they were kind of mad but they're kind
of mad about everything so
i don't really know so uh eventually i
will get around to watching it there's
so much stuff i gotta like keep up with
holy crap but you know what i'm saying
um
yeah you said it's excellent okay well
yeah it definitely sounds cool and i'm
gonna check it out because
uh it is mike flanagan yeah because i
like all his stuff
um let's see where
oh thank you
uh i've heard that north korea doesn't
have electricity is that true and why i
can't imagine a modern society without
that
[Laughter]
it's so funny
no north korea doesn't have electricity
we're talking about
only pyongyang has electricity which is
the capital city
and uh you made a big mistake thinking
that north korea was a modern [ __ ]
country it's not a modern country
well it's i mean even the whole
just that whole uh
the capital city is just kind of like a
shell pretty much because that's just
kind of what they want to show everybody
because most of those buildings are like
empty
no no no no no no not north
well the government buildings are that's
what i meant yeah but they they actually
have apartments everything
um
pyongyang
yep okay
north korea is not a country as you
would know it
the dprk
is a political party
that has conquered north korea
it lives in this in the central city in
pyongyang the capital city everyone else
has po has been conquered
it's a situation kind of like hunger
games
you know what i mean where the people in
the
the the loyal party members and the in
the descendants of the loyal party are
in pyongyang they are in the party
everyone else is kind of like a natural
resource a conquered person they're kind
of like the natives you know what i mean
and they serve the state
but they're so low on the totem pole
they don't even propagandize them
they don't even know any they don't even
have political ideology
each city has been
tailored to have like maybe one function
like to load trains on training dock
another city does nothing but just like
i don't know mine something
uh other ones whole swales of the area
have been depopulated
it was starved out in what in their
version of kind of like what they call
it the the long hungry march
back in the
early 90s when their economy finally
totally imploded
uh a [ __ ] large
portion of the population starved
which helped north korea out a lot
because now it didn't have so many miles
to feed
you see
economies are about supply and demand
and communism cannot supply the demand
because they cannot produce enough so
what they do is they reduce the demand
to fit the supply
so what what that means is
uh
if you're gonna if you've got a hundred
people but you can only feed ten
you let 90 of them die reduce the demand
so
so you have the 10 people that you feed
and then you call that a success
because you just got rid of excess
population these are the people that you
didn't need
so
and it's not
it's communism but it's not it they'll
come out and tell you that it's it's
juche communism it's north korean
communism
it's their interpretation their
interpretation of
the soviet union when they saw what was
going on in north korea they were like
[ __ ] that they didn't want to even do
that [ __ ] okay
it's
set up more like a traditional north
korea it's set up more like a
traditional korean kingdom
which is the worship of a god emperor
a um an imperial an imperial cult
that's conquered an area
and
it controls peasants
rice farming peasants that's basically
what it is
sarah was laughing at uh ease because
he's like uh doing the gilligan's island
theme song no phones no lights no motor
cars not a single luxury
yeah
sesame says i love how kim jong-un
claims he's so perfect that he doesn't
even pee or poo
[Laughter]
he's smooth like a ken doll that doesn't
that that's not kim jong-un all right
that goes back even to his grandfather
well that's everybody well if you're
like if you're a god you can't if you're
a god then you'd mean to you don't
really have bodily functions okay
because nobody wants to grow up but
here's the thing he's not saying that
all right um the propaganda
religious propaganda
network that has always been around the
dprk does that automatically
it's kind of weird you would think that
if you were the emperor you would have
total control over everything and they
kind of
don't in a certain way
certain things happen automatically
like
kim jong-un does not sit around worrying
about what's going to be on the state
propaganda radio or the news
it
it spins its own [ __ ] according to
laws that were given to it
[ __ ] decades ago well whoever's in
there it's like no they don't have snot
no they don't have ass boys yeah right
yeah yeah right right right they don't
have any human qualities with it yeah
they're godlike they're god like they're
like living statues
and that you know they don't actually
die they're translated directly into
heaven [ __ ] doves come down and
escort their souls
back to [ __ ] mountain nice man dude
that's like some snow white [ __ ] right
yeah yeah yeah yeah and one of the
little woodland animals come in like
sorting all your [ __ ] you would think
that was [ __ ] you must be a very
powerful
dictator to [ __ ] tell the news people
to [ __ ] lie like that no not at all
they do it automatically they're [ __ ]
born bred and [ __ ]
raised by a [ __ ] machine
that programs them to lie like that
automatically
according to certain methods that were
been in place for decades
just like a cult exactly like a
religious code well uh going on from
that mr roboto asked a very interesting
question tom could scientology grow and
survive in north korea yes
oh i'm sure yeah i don't think they
would think that it was anything that
unusual
here's the thing
is that north korea is that that's
exactly why that's what i mean it's very
much the same they have something called
the juche ideal see kim uh
kimio song
wrote or supposedly wrote an entire
library of books about
independence and juche which is you know
independence and survival and national
survival and it's kind of like their
holy manuscript their holy books it's
kind of like l ron hubbard's [ __ ]
yeah okay
here's the thing
they print that [ __ ] library and it's
like 30 40 50 books they print it over
and over again
they give it as gifts to people they
have it everywhere evidently nobody ever
reads it
so just like the scientist just like
scientology nobody ever reads it
nobody really knows exactly what it says
uh there are some people that know all
about it and can quote it but they quote
they cherry pick and say certain things
out of it to get what they want
and you know i mean it's usually some
kind of government official well in book
33 you know this and the books are about
everything how to [ __ ] write operas
and how to do
theater and how to generate electricity
and how into the juvenile [ __ ] that's
what scientology is exactly l ron
hubbard
because obviously he's the most
awesomest person that ever lived and he
knows how to do everything in the best
way possible yeah and he wrote about
pretty much everything yeah he was like
a [ __ ] physicist and everything yeah
well there used to be a bunch of north
korean propaganda
there used to be a bunch of north korean
propaganda films
on youtube
uh about uh kim jong-il i actually like
kim jong-il the best out of them all
because he was the craziest all right
he wasn't crazy he was just weird man
it's like
you have to know him to yeah you have to
[ __ ]
you know you don't know that i don't
really talk about what he did i know
everything he did and know the
personality
he was kind of like the misfit of his
family he was kind of like the geeky
nerd who ended up be becoming [ __ ]
ruler of [ __ ] the dprk
and um
they had a whole bunch of in the in the
80s they had a whole whole series of
propaganda films
put out about him and there have been
they're translated into english for
international consumption
and
each film is about something that the
dear leader can do
one of them was just how good he was as
a director and how he
revolutionized
theater
like you know what i mean he could do
everything about [ __ ] how to write
musicals dance
he's an expert on every [ __ ] thing
and each north korean propaganda film
shows him on tour showing up to north
korean factories and actually teaching
people
how to [ __ ] do it better you know how
to make
chickens lay more eggs [ __ ] it and it's
just it's the [ __ ] funniest [ __ ]
thing ever when you think about it it's
all about chicken vaginal massage
[Laughter]
of creation and [ __ ] you know just
like what the hell but see that every
time like i read stuff about scientology
i'm just like that sounds pretty much
exactly like north korea
any kind of cult it's not just
scientology but any kind of cult they
they use those methods because those
methods work they work yeah um you know
and hate to say it
uh people who you know you think you're
a free people and that you're
enlightened and better than the ancients
and better than
most
governments
are a form of theocracy
they just couch it in new
thinking
uh they get around it but there's always
kind of like a state religion behind it
um
and america is that too it's always kind
of had a state religion it's just that
instead of saying it's a religion they
would just say it's an ideology
um
or a political bend
if you look at republicans and democrats
an ancient person would have regarded
those as religions in the way
you know the things that they believe in
having a religious quality to it
uh they're secular religions yeah well
okay here's here's an exact george
washington cut down the cherry tree
it's not true it never happened
but they taught little kids that when i
was a little kid they t they taught us
all these little
stories and fables and it's like a
secular religion you know um
look at he never told a lie
all kinds of stuff about paul bunyan
all kinds of stuff about uh [ __ ] um
what else did did they teach us yeah
there's a whole whole there's not like
american mythology like american
mythology
and you know governments do that hold on
one second
yeah what's going on
i just like i keep hearing something
like somebody left a tv on or something
like that i keep hearing something out
of the thing
what do you think about the americans
who willingly defected to
north korea were there a lot of those i
don't really know i haven't really heard
that much about that so i don't really
know why you would
willingly do that to yourself but you
know takes all sorts i guess
uh cessp says angry gay pope was quiet
for a while but seems to be posting a
few
more things again lately yeah i wonder
what happened to him like we're on his
facebook they were out there [ __ ]
fighting oh yeah
bad kids okay we got him there's
knocking [ __ ] over i'm telling you man
pookie cannot resist she sees beijing
walk by with that big fluffy butt and
she's just like
i gotta jump on it but then she thinks
about it should i jump on it yes i
should totally jump on it and then
beijing gets all mad
um alex's menorah says what do you think
about the americans who willingly
defected to north korea
oh like [ __ ] um oh what's his name
like i said have there been that many of
these
joe dresnock
yeah yeah there were some
uh i don't really know what
you know they didn't actually defect
in the way you think that they did they
were running from the us army because
they were [ __ ] running from charges
and
well yeah so that's a different
situation
that's just like oh my god north korea
is so awesome let's go over there it's
just like well i'm gonna get like
[ __ ]
arrested or killed if i don't i don't
remember exactly what dresnock did
dreznock i think [ __ ]
punched a [ __ ] a
superior officer and [ __ ] stole a
jeep
and then uh
ran across the border to escape [ __ ]
punishment it's oh it's always usually
something like that
yeah so it's not anybody really running
there because they think it's awesome
and not just trying to get away from
something they're trying to get away
from punishment
and then cessp said angry gay pope was
quiet for a while but seems to be
posting a few more things again lately
yeah
i hadn't seen anything new that he'd
posted like i said we're both on his
facebook um
and
but i hadn't like i hadn't seen anything
new that he was posting i'll have to go
and check because he was always such a
good guest to have
he's so fun
pookie and beijing watch hbo max they
probably do
they have little they get along most of
the time grudgingly
i'm glad that they actually kind of
chilled out because when pookie first
came when she was really little beijing
was not having it she did not like
this little baby like in her domain and
she's still not really happy about it
but
pookie doesn't care
she wants she's just she she just thinks
it's funny and she is not scared of
beijing at all even though beijing is
like twice her size they're going to
love the house though well yeah that's
what i mean somebody somebody was asking
earlier how they had adapted the new
house i said they haven't been there yet
yeah and i'm really people think that
we've moved no we haven't well because
because this looks this is the same
studio it's just everything's gone yeah
so i just haven't set up the new one yet
i gotta go tomorrow
and
put pictures on the wall i got the
bookshelves there i got one desk there i
got two more desks out and put together
that's gonna have all the streaming [ __ ]
on it and then i'm gonna do my gallery
wall in the background so i'm gonna do
that tomorrow hopefully and get it all
done how long have you been streaming uh
hour and a half okay hour and a half it
might be uh
we might let it run for a little bit
longer
because i gotta break this [ __ ] down
that's right i'm gonna get this taken
out i'm gonna break that thing apart and
take that other thing apart what time is
it now uh it is 7 30. okay it's about 7
30. i mean it's a heavy trash day
that's right yeah gotta throw out half
this damn [ __ ]
half this damn [ __ ] yeah well at least
we got most of the stuff
like i said i don't think
i'm trying to think what i gotta take
off of here because i still need to use
this tomorrow so i can't like unhook it
all these boxes are gonna load those up
in the car in the morning
okay well i'll take them over in the
morning you gotta go in the uh cars and
then a bunch of clothes because we got
the big u-haul tomorrow before we just
have you guys coming tomorrow like last
time we just had the like the little
u-haul yeah
to just take the little
washer but this is the big long truck
so this take and the dudes you have
three higher education i just i actually
just needed these dudes to help me pick
this [ __ ] up
i'm glad i don't have to help you pick
stuff up and like i said most of the
stuff we're taking is going downstairs
like the refrigerator and the couches
and stuff i think the beds
yeah so the bed's the only thing that
has to go upstairs but man we're getting
so much exercise walking up downstairs
yeah
carrying boxes up and down the stairs
i'm just
i i don't okay i know this is like maybe
irrational if any of you guys have cats
and you live in a two-story house please
tell me
that the cats know better
than to like jump off the [ __ ] second
floor
because yeah they know better
because this is worrying me because look
um
you know the stairs it's kind of like it
goes like that and like that you know
what i mean it's not like just one
staircase it's you know divided or
whatever
but on the top like right where your
office is going to be
there are the slats for the staircase
and it's like it looks right over
like the foyer living room type of area
and it's tile floor
and pookie could probably fit through
those slats
she's worried too and i feel like what
if she just decided hey i'm going to
like fall out of there yeah and then she
like broke her little legs or something
i would be so excited
cats have awesome [ __ ] death
perception i know but
they can also i'm always kind of like
yeah but i'm like a long distance can we
just like put a big fluffy rug
like at the base of the stairs the cat
will not make that jump or something
just see well [ __ ] i wouldn't say she's
i don't think she's gonna jump on
purpose but what if she fell like by
accident i don't know i'm worried about
it cats do not fall by accident
have you seen that video of i don't know
how this ended up
but there's a pretty famous
uh it's probably several years old but
if this cat like on a balcony i don't
even know how many stories up it was and
the cat was just sitting on the balcony
all of a sudden went
and just like jumped off
and i don't really know how far down was
it i don't know
it looked uh kind of high up
because every time i see that i'm like
what happened to that cat
i don't know it just it worried me like
when we were looking at the house that
was one thing that kind of worried me
and i was like maybe we should put like
some clear plastic like against these
because i'm like ridiculous
well you know ridiculous she's my baby
but it's not far she's my baby i worry
about that it's not far down there
well to me it looks far because i'm that
far
dude i get up on a chair and i have a
panic attack because it's like i do not
like heights
i've so i've been like in the bathroom
painting
and i have a chair in there and like a
step ladder and stuff and i'm like
trying to get i'm edging the ceiling in
the bathroom and i had to like stand up
on the bathroom counter like to get up
onto the ceiling and i was just like i
was freaking out i'm like
dude i'm like
three feet off the ground and it's like
it's too high for me
because my balance is [ __ ] up because
i have inner ear problems so it's like i
so i i'm like three feet up and i'm just
kind of like oh my god i'm gonna fall
i'm gonna bust my head open oh my god
so it's like that kind of [ __ ]
uh camp guy says my cats also climb all
the way up to the roof and they have to
go run the softener upside down
we had didn't beijing
in the place you used to live
remember that place on uh
that kind of town house that on douglas
used to live on yeah didn't beijing get
up on the roof there and jump off yeah
now that wasn't two stories no one story
but it was like it was still pretty high
and she jumped off she was young back
then she liked it i'll top it out
well she would get up there and she was
like oh [ __ ] now i'm up on the roof how
do i get down oh okay now then i'll jump
well she was chasing squirrels that's
right and she's like how do i get myself
into these situations
well for a long time when she was little
you didn't let her outside yeah you
didn't let her outside until she was
older she was fascinated with squirrels
and possums
yeah
she would chase possum and not try to
and then when she'd run up on it she
wouldn't catch it she'd just look and go
oh oh
it's an ugly kitty
daddy look look
look at that
shit's ugly
possums are [ __ ] ugly no they're not
they're they're ugly if you're a cat
then that [ __ ] is [ __ ] ugly i kind of
feel like
i feel like cats are cat centric they
think that everything well it's just
kind of like humans you humanize
everything so cats
catify everything yeah um they see
humans probably as big cats without hair
that walk on two legs so i kind of feel
like whenever they see another animal
that's like oh that's a weird looking
cat yeah i do kind of feel like when
they see because beijing loves raccoons
right she loves raccoons every time she
writes she's like oh
god look at these things look at those
beautiful kitties
they're so stripy you can tell
you can tell she's immediately trying to
give her a [ __ ] [ __ ] she's
immediately trying to go
she's like these things are so [ __ ]
awesome she's rolling around
yeah she's trying to get laid trying to
get laid beijing is weird yeah she loves
her
interest species relationships but just
not like possums but like you said i
kind of feel like possums are like ugly
kitties yeah they kind of approach them
like they're ugly kitties
pookie ran up to that
that raccoon also remember yeah
yeah she's like look look at it look at
it look at that
she's trying to i gotta i got it in the
flashlight she's like look at this thing
look at this thing that's awesome
well wasn't she we went out there one
time and she was sitting by the tree in
our backyard hanging out with the
[ __ ] pup and the pirate
and the raccoon was just sitting there
and they were sitting there together
yeah
and tom went out there with a flashlight
and she's just like look at this thing
look
yeah yeah
look what i found
it's weird you would think that [ __ ]
cats and raccoons would fight but no
they [ __ ] love each other yeah for
some reason they don't um possums and
cats are different because the possums
just start running and the cat's like
look at that thing well
it's the devil i had a cat uh when i was
younger
and
my cat she was grown
she got attacked by a possum
i think what happened was that the
possum got into the laundry room we had
a laundry but it was like outside it was
like off the porch
and the possum got in there somehow i
guess somebody like left the door open
so the possum got in there and then the
cat went in there the possum scared her
and then they fought
and the possum actually
bit her in the bit my cat in the face
and tore a part of her lip off
so she had to go to the vet and
everything like that
but
i don't it's really weird because i kind
of feel like i don't know raccoons in
the she didn't get any fights with
raccoons though says we already did a
house tour video
well i did when it was empty
when they when the office and stuff is
all set up i'm going to do like an
office tour and i'm going to show you
guys the upper floor parts of the upper
floor yeah because the the bottom floor
i'm just like bored with it it's like i
don't even know
but the upper floor we're gonna do all
kind of cool [ __ ] up there the um
it's like uh
i saw the video that she posted it
really doesn't um
it doesn't really give you the depth of
how big it is up on top floor it's
pretty big it's bigger than this whole
house on top floor i mean
i when we went to see a nice layout it's
gonna be like a nightclub upstairs i got
lights gonna picked out for it but it's
gonna take time there's a lot of [ __ ]
and man look i'm gonna tell you guys
truth bro
i'm worried about that electric bill
that thing runs two air conditioners
and i got it it's florida and it's two
floors yeah so we're kind of worried i
mean the okay so this house air
conditioning bill might be like a
thousand we'll see i'm hoping it won't
be
this house push that [ __ ] down to 75 and
it's not really that hot at 75 in there
because
when we when we first went there yeah um
you know the our landlords who owned the
house yeah they had it at 79. it wasn't
that bad and it wasn't bad it wasn't hot
in there if you had if you had the
thermostat at 79 in this house
you would be dying yeah you would be
dying we keep it at least 72. we keep it
at 72 in this house yeah because like i
said it's like 4 million degrees outside
but so we like i said we haven't lived
in a two-story house
so we're not sure how this is gonna go
uh the electric bill here is what 300
something well the thing is we've been
here for so long we were able to average
it yeah it's averaged out
and i think you have to be here about
three years before they'll be able to
average out your bill yeah which and
they won't let us do that up there
so we're going to pay every month which
means we
but at least we're moving in in the fall
and winter so maybe summer months are
going to hit us
and we're going to have to pay the true
monthly bill but i'm hoping and that
[ __ ] is going to be about 800 bucks a
month i bet you god i hope not
i don't know we'll have to see we're
going to need some super jets but it has
but it has two air conditioners right or
it has like a big air conditioner
there's one outside unit and two inside
units
because this house this is only one
story
um
and we've had a lot of problems with
this air conditioning it's we just have
like a regular they replaced it a couple
times but it breaks down
you know
since they've replaced it since they
replaced it but before that it would
break down like at least once a summer
because
like i said this is florida yeah air
conditioners are not really built to
withstand
the the work punishment the work that it
has to put in to keep your house cool it
depends on what it is
yeah a lot of houses like this
we're built with bare minimum
[ __ ] um
units the size
just enough to sell the house their
their houses were built here quickly
and they built to sell quickly
back in those days this is this house is
what close to 20 years old now no it's
um
maybe more like 15 my 15. i think when
we moved into it i think it was maybe 10
years old so they'll they'll kind of put
the bare minimum unit out there
it might not be the best quality you're
not talking about carrier
the best air conditioner is a carrier
and it may be a little small they're
just trying to sell the [ __ ] house
over time you know [ __ ] as it pass as
different owners have it they'll put a
better unit it's got a better unit out
there now
it's a lot bigger than the original
so it it doesn't have to work as hard
as we drove through here i'll look on
the side of some of these houses and
they have two small units
yeah and i was like man that should have
been replaced with one bigger one that's
not as efficient
you know having two little ones two
little ones it's not as efficient
but this one has one large one yeah the
one we're moving to has one really big
one large outside unit two smaller and
then there's two and so there's a
thermostat downstairs and a third i'm
gonna have upstairs yeah two different
squirrel cages i think they're called
compressors
no no condensers what's it called
compressors outside i think the
condenser inside what's called so we're
hoping that it's more energy efficient
we'll see
we'll see because if we get the first
electric bill and next summer man we're
gonna i'm gonna run that [ __ ] at about
75 just to be sure
i don't want to get hit with a thousand
dollar [ __ ] electric bill yeah [ __ ]
oh my god i should [ __ ] [ __ ] my pants
yeah where it's like two hundred dollars
a month yeah oh man electricity no big
deal then [ __ ] summer month hits you
to a thousand ah
yeah and like you said you have to be
living somewhere usually for like three
years before they let you average it
average it out right because it's better
if you average it out that's what we do
here
um so the electric vehicle you know what
you're gonna pay is about 300 odds right
a month which is a lot but
it's better than paying like nothing in
the winter and then paying like a
thousand dollars in the summer so this
is robotics it's central air more alexa
we're just telling you right now bro
listen to this listen well okay i will
say in florida everything's more
expensive here you have to have central
like you have to have central air yeah
honestly you can live without heat yeah
you don't need heat i have gone entire
years i've gone years without turning
the heat on
we well we turn the heat on uh maybe
like a couple
a week or so after out of the day i
don't even know if it's a week
last year
how many times did we turn the heat on
twice twice
was like burning hair assisted [ __ ]
alarms off in here
because the damn ducks are [ __ ]
falling off that's how seldom we turn
the heat on when you turn it on one it
smells like burning hair through the
whole house
smoke alarms off
because we never turn never turn it on
because it never gets golden enough on
those heating units it never gets cold
enough
even when it's cold in the house and
he's just like should we turn the heat
on i'm like please don't i would rather
just pile more blankets on or put on a
sweater
it's like it's too much hassle so but
i've got an entire
i've got entire years without turning
the heat on in the house like but even
before i was here the thing is is the
heat is a much cheaper
than than than cooling it's much cheaper
it is yeah it doesn't yeah cooling
cooling at florida house [ __ ] costs a
lot more because i mean we've said this
before in florida
it really it very very rarely goes under
freezing
very rare yeah and even if it does it
it's only like a night or two
see look some people [ __ ] like i was
i was i was talking to boy [ __ ] who
he's a hollywood [ __ ] sound dude
and uh he's lived here in florida before
he said man you should move back we went
to school together
so you should move back he knows russell
and so you should move back here it's
like nah he's living in burbank
he says no man i lived there already i
just couldn't take the heat i was like
yeah there's only one bad thing about
florida it's the [ __ ] heat if you do
not like heat do not move here yeah it
will die
three or four months out of the year
it's [ __ ] bad and i was born here and
i still can't stand southern it's pretty
bad
it's a lot hotter than mississippi it's
[ __ ] dagobah
but there's something to be said for it
it's an obstacle to keep out the weak it
keeps those [ __ ] out here you
gotta be [ __ ] tough to come here you
don't want every [ __ ] [ __ ]
from california or new york moving down
here [ __ ] up to your environment and
sucking down on and then charging you
for parking and buying businesses and
trying to run new york scams they're
trying to go down look i know
everything's going on
[ __ ] online watching
i lived in a for a while i lived in a
[ __ ] apartment complex it was owned
by some guys from new york
and they were trying to charge everybody
to try to pull all these new york scams
like try to charge you for parking in
your own parking space in your own dev
apartment complex then they try to
charge you for [ __ ]
some places trash
take out some places here do that too
yeah but that's those are dudes from new
york and they [ __ ] lost all their
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then they had to back
off on that because people started
moving out
you can't run those scams here in
florida
because it's not new york and it's not
la
in new york and la and a [ __ ] lived
in the northeast and born in california
actually
which
i liked california when it was good
this is not a captive audience
if they don't like what you're doing
they just move
it's not the situation you know i mean
in [ __ ] places in new york it's a lot
harder to move everywhere you go is just
like that and if if you want to move
away from it then you have to leave new
york city
say but florida isn't like that you can
go anywhere in florida and get a
fantastic [ __ ] house
and uh so if you mistreat people they
just move
they don't have to do business with you
it's not new york
and it's not la
so it's a lot tougher to survive here in
terms of your if you're a predator
and you're trying to make money off of
[ __ ] people and treat them like
cattle you're not really able to do it
here
especially not in miami
i've said this before on other channels
and [ __ ] verified it with people who
[ __ ] live in the very southern tip of
florida
if you're not cuban and have
you're going to have a problem sometime
or if you're not cuban friendly if the
cubans turn against you south americans
turn again because that's not america
down there that's [ __ ] central
america i'm totally comfortable there i
haven't lived in brazil i [ __ ] love
that environment love that culture
miami's pretty cool actually yeah i'm
for in my heart jenny would [ __ ]
testify i'm very latino and i have a
very latin [ __ ] spirit growing up in
sao paulo brazil
i like that sensibility it's a lot more
emotion
uh it's a lot more of an honor based
society
it's not so much about laws it's about
honor you know and
you can't go down in [ __ ] south
florida and [ __ ] around they will kill
you literally they'll [ __ ] kill you
that's [ __ ] central america
but they're going to be cool about it
you respect them they respect you you
disrespect them they'll [ __ ] you over
they will [ __ ] you over and that goes
along into business
when big tom and i and some of these
other guys were down there [ __ ] in uh
downtown over here in stanford talking
about all those clubs like man we need a
[ __ ] some cubans in this [ __ ]
arrangement here [ __ ] we got to get
the cuban angle
because they want to take over that town
with clubs and [ __ ] which i got we got
this move has [ __ ] me up
well it's still it's not that far stop
that no it [ __ ] me up time wise
because i got to get back over there big
tom and we
we had some [ __ ] planned
well we moved soon
in a week or two you can go back down
there and get back up with that we had
some [ __ ] planned
about that that [ __ ]
well yeah because where mannequins is we
have another friend
uh who we know through eyebar we've
known for many many years
and he's opening a club down there too
right uh so they're planning like a
whole kind of club
takeover we're going to take over at
[ __ ] downtown clubs we got and
downtown sanford is pretty cool it's
very small yeah but it's pretty cool
there's like some cool like antique
shops like used bookstores like all kind
of cool restaurants it's very
very cool kind of already kind of vibe
down there downtown orlando because
what's happening with covid and the
economy and everything is becoming less
viable
so well it's expensive coming too
expensive it's expensive and people
aren't going down there like they used
to and the liquor licenses
in downtown orlando they're stupid so
really
the future is in the suburban sprawl
and there's going to be a bunch of cool
[ __ ] happening in the suburban sprawl
and safford
downtown sanford has a lot of [ __ ] um
good prospects and tom's next bar that
he's building is going to be f it's a
high-end
[ __ ] old man bar
like basically and i s and
[ __ ] scott's gonna be in on that well
they're doing a whole they're doing like
an old
almost like a great gatsby gatsby like
art deco kind of yeah high-end like
cigar bar like super like and it's gonna
have really cute waitresses and
bartenders there that climb up on these
down ladders to go get a hundred dollar
shots of [ __ ] whiskey and come down
and make it you're looking up people's
skirts they're going to give you up
shots and [ __ ] and it's going to be fun
and [ __ ] it's funny because me and
big tom and scott are down there [ __ ]
looking at the construction as it's
going and guess the cops come up
and [ __ ] tom's already [ __ ] in
with the local cops he's introduced me a
little guy it's something else when the
cops know you see
so [ __ ]
big tom's like
i ain't gonna [ __ ] sleep he's like
look at this is my little look at my
little boy here
he's jacked show me muscles he's got me
out there [ __ ] doing [ __ ] posing
routines for the cops
well like i said downtown sanford is
very small yeah but it's only like a few
blocks but it's a cool little area and
there's like a lot of really cool little
shops and restaurants down that's where
chantal's is yeah yeah which is where
and where mannequins is
and big tom
and gina or miriam yeah they have been
wanting to open a bar we met them at
ibarr years and years and years ago
almost 15 years ago yeah it was a long
time ago and big tom has been talking
about we called big tom um he's been
talking about opening his own club for
ages and we're so happy that he finally
did it and it's like man he opened that
little bitty place and then he like
bought the place next door yeah tore the
wall out
expanded it and it's just kind of like
mannequins is like doing really good and
so
some of our other friends from eyebar is
like yeah man we want to go down we want
to get in on that yeah because like i
said downtown orlando is cool but it's
very expensive yeah i don't really have
the money to [ __ ] run with these
dudes but if i can scott's like dude
we're going to get you on don't worry
about the money [ __ ] we're going to
get you in on this and [ __ ] we're
going to make money we're going to take
over this town and if we wanted to do
all these concerts at the [ __ ]
civic center yeah they got a civic
center [ __ ] fantasy and they want to
bring in like some big like bigger shows
big shows
civic center
and it doesn't cost that much and then
you have liquor rights there see
so you can make a lot of money there for
the decent event like i said liquor
license much cheaper right than it is in
downtown orlando
what's the liquor license in downtown
orlando at the last time i checked it's
like a hundred thousand it's like at
least a quarter mil it was yeah
i think it's i think it's a quarter mile
it's ridiculous
you know here it's like a couple grand
but then like uh
so we do jenny's uh design company does
all the graphics and all the promotion
for big toms
fermented mannequins big thompson all
their theme nights i do i do all the
posters and stuff for all the things
yeah yeah
you know but uh this move has [ __ ] us
up in terms of like uh but it's not it's
the scheduling not the location it's
only another
well it's not our fault it's just it
kind of got sprung upon us at the last
minute
but you know it is what it is
and honestly i really really like the
new house
um it's a little farther out but
it's not that big a deal we had to drive
that we had a drive far to downtown
orlando anyway
um
you know another 10 minutes driving into
mannequins it's not really that big a
deal i don't really care about it
so
you know yeah
it'll be all right all right so how long
we've been streaming jenny
one hour and 54 minutes yeah we should
make it a two-hour show nadine says what
themes do they have there on what um at
mannequins let's see i'm trying to think
it was like
i've done so many posters you guys
uh the theme that they did last night
was
cheap ass halloween
costumes where you were supposed to wear
your worst halloween costume that you
got from like the dollar store and they
would give you a prize for like and they
had like trick-or-treat [ __ ] like in the
club you could trick-or-treat in the
club they had candy and [ __ ] like that
they were given out
um let's see they've done
one theme they're doing
next month
or in november they're gonna do like a
great gatsby kind of theme which is cool
prior to that they did like um a sci-fi
theme we did remember we did apocalypse
yeah like zombie apocalypse or mad max
kind of theme yeah i did the mad max
thing it showed up as a war boy and [ __ ]
and won it and then tom goes man you get
out of here because you're not allowed
to wait
well that's why it's like i like to
dress up for it sometimes but we're not
gonna win he's like that's not fair man
your staff
they did uh oh they did gothic beauty
pageant yeah they did a gothic beauty
pageant
they did
trying to think of like some other
themes that i did um they're gonna do i
don't know if they've done this yet but
they did a mad hatter like an alice in
wonderland
mad hatter theme they did that
um
trying to think of some other [ __ ] but
each night it's different they even have
they have either each weekend karaoke
there too they have that's during the
week on the weekends weekend's a lot
bigger friday night saturday night are
usually like goth industrial new wave
punk
stuff i've posted videos of it me
molesting jenny there and [ __ ] on my
[ __ ] instagram
yeah you know you can see the inside of
it on instagram most of it was during
kind of the slow hours because
to be honest with shit's really [ __ ]
rolling i don't have time to pull out a
[ __ ]
yeah we so we usually film stuff like
early before people get there yeah
because we usually show up early so we
can get nice and drunk before it gets
there well we kind of have to it's kind
of like our job to kind of show up a
little bit early to [ __ ] make sure
everything else said it's a job because
it's just part of us and what we do in
the scene you know i mean we got we got
to [ __ ] hang out with the [ __ ]
club owners and [ __ ] you know make
sure if he's good talk business and have
fun and get some relaxing drinks in and
you know warm the place up and then see
who shows up and then [ __ ] start
kickstarting [ __ ] and [ __ ] start
starting trouble making sure everybody's
having a good time entertaining and
supervising and [ __ ] doing the kind
of same [ __ ] we do with you guys you
know i mean [ __ ] all the regulars
showing up making sure everybody's all
welcome
clubs are social events you know what i
mean you got to make sure everybody's
[ __ ] well yeah you gotta you gotta
make sure everybody's having a good time
yeah and then that you're making sure
everything's happening you know oh i
just thought of some other themes
next week i think next weekend i think
they're doing a rocky horror theme okay
um
also for paul vayne's birthday yeah he's
the dj by the way um they did for
whatever reason
knight of the cryptids
so they did like bigfoot mothman they
did all that kind of stuff yeah that was
the theme they did that night so they're
all kind of like goth weird stuff
that kind of stuff so it's all kind of
like dark themed but this is at like
every weekend they're trying to do a
different theme but yeah
yeah all right
no we got a lot of work to do you got a
little work to do you got a lot of work
to do and you seem to want to just uh do
the show all night man we i got to break
this [ __ ] down
all right yeah we gotta i gotta be
drinking and i gotta take this desk
apart yeah
we're actually no i'm gonna break it
apart we're bringing the sledgehammer in
here i'm just gonna break it apart into
pieces okay well i guess i gotta get
everything you gotta get everything off
of it and all because i bought new desks
i got a [ __ ] three and a half foot
long sledgehammer i'm gonna come in here
okay well i gotta make sure and take
everything out of my drawers
we can shut it down all right so we
gotta go yeah because tom has to like
break this up with a sledgehammer yeah
so i have to move everything make sure
he didn't break any my [ __ ] yeah all
right so
we will be back on hopefully wednesday
night
if i get everything set up at the new
house hopefully the office and studio
will be set up at the new house by
wednesday night so we can do a sidetrack
show from there um but thank you
everybody for dropping by hanging out
with me on my birthday
and uh you know it's been a really good
time had a good time hanging out with
you guys we will see you guys on
wednesday hopefully so have a good rest
of your weekend i know there's not much
of it left and we will see you guys on
wednesday
bye